in this city where the first vaccine was
given as the government announced its
winter vaccine plan we went to meet a
rock band to discuss living with covid
who else but the vaccines performing at
the empire in coventry on a five-week
tour
they're reveling in being back in the
spotlight but if the latest strategy
doesn't work some concerts and large
events face further restrictions nobody
wants to contemplate the lights going
out again
you know it's been really difficult like
we rely on connection and community and
packing
hundreds of thousands of people into
tight spaces like this that's you know
that's sort of our bread and butter it's
like the bread and butter of our crew
that come on tour with us and all that
sort of thing so you know we haven't
really
really haven't worked for the last 18
months it's been really tough do you
ever regret calling yourself the
vaccines
do we ever regret calling ourselves the
vaccines you know it hasn't been too bad
the odd the odd dad joke here and there
but nothing
nothing too bad
in coventry last december 91 year old
margaret keenan became the first person
in the uk to receive a vaccine outside
of clinical trials since then all adults
have been offered a jab
for sarah jane hennessy running a fancy
dress shop in the city is a family
affair which is why she's embracing her
daughter who's nearly 12 having the
vaccine in the interests of those who
are more vulnerable
i do think that probably 20 30 years ago
this is how parents might have felt
about
the means or mumps from rubella
whatever sort of things we've had to
have for vaccinations i think covert is
here to stay
gladys trickett is 104 years old and
survived getting covered but nursing
homes like the belvedere in coventry are
bracing for the second winter of the
pandemic
they haven't lost anyone here to the
virus and the booster program can't come
soon enough i think it's wonderful news
i think it's going to really really
um
bring some more security and safety to
the lives of everybody that live here
it's been a long time since everybody's
had their second
dose which was in april this year so
they've gone six months
young or old booster or first jab the
government believes getting a vaccine is
the way for normal life to continue this
winter lisa holland sky news coventry